Let's see how
regression trees do.
We'll first load
the rpart library
and also load the
rpart plotting library.
We build a regression
tree in the same way
we would build a classification
tree, using the rpart command.
We predict MEDV as a function
of latitude and longitude,
using the Boston dataset.
If we now plot the tree
using the prp command, which
is to find an rpart.plot, we
can see it makes a lot of splits
and is a little bit
hard to interpret.
But the important thing
is look at the leaves.
In a classification
tree, the leaves
would be the
classification we assign
that these splits
would apply to.
But in regression trees, we
instead predict a number.
That number is the average
of the median house
prices in that bucket or leaf.
So let's see what that
means in practice.
So we'll plot again the
latitude-- the points.
And we'll again plot the points
with above median prices.
I just scrolled up from my
command history to do that.
Now we want to predict
what the tree thinks
is above median, just like we
did with linear regression.
So we'll say the
fitted values we
can get from using the predict
command on the tree we just
built.
And we can do another
points command,
just like we did before.
The fitted values are greater
than 21.2 The color is blue.
And the character
is a dollar sign.
Now we see that we've
done a much better job
than linear regression
was able to do.
We've correctly left the
low value area in Boston
and below out, and
we've correctly
managed to classify
some of those points
in the bottom right
and top right.
We're still making
mistakes, but we're
able to make a
nonlinear prediction
on latitude and longitude.
So that's interesting, but
the tree was very complicated.
So maybe it's
drastically overfitting.
Can we get most of this effect
with a much simpler tree?
We can.
We would just change
the minbucket size.
So let's build a new tree
using the rpart command again:
MEDV as a function of LAT
and LON, the data=boston.
But this time we'll say the
minbucket size must be 50.
We'll use the other way
of plotting trees, plot,
and we'll add text
to the text command.
And we see we have
far fewer splits,
and it's far more interpretable.
The first split says
if the longitude
is greater than or equal
to negative 71.07--
so if you're on the right
side of the picture.
So the left-hand branch
is on the left-hand side
of the picture and
the right-hand--
So the left-hand
side of the tree
corresponds to the
right-hand side of the map.
And the right side of
the tree corresponds
to the left side of the map.
That's a little
bit of a mouthful.
Let's see what it
means visually.
So we'll remember
these values, and we'll
plot the longitude
and latitude again.
So here's our map.
OK.
So the first split
was on longitude,
and it was negative 71.07.
So there's a very handy
command, "abline,"
which can put horizontal
or vertical lines easily.
So we're going to put
a vertical line, so v,
and we wanted to plot
it at negative 71.07.
OK.
So that's that first
split from the tree.
It corresponds to being on
either the left or right-hand
side of this tree.
We'll plot the-- what we want to
do is, we'll focus on one area.
We'll focus on the lowest
price prediction, which
is in the bottom left
corner of the tree,
right down the bottom left
after all those splits.
So that's where
we want to get to.
So let's plot again the points.
Plot a vertical line.
The next split down towards
that bottom left corner
was a horizontal line at 42.21.
So I put that in.
That's interesting.
So that line corresponds
pretty much to where
the Charles River
was from before.
The final split you need to get
to that bottom left corner I
was pointing out is 42.17.
It was above this line.
And now that's interesting.
If we look at the right side
of the middle of the three
rectangles on the
right side, that
is the bucket we
were predicting.
And it corresponds to that
rectangle, those areas.
That's the South Boston low
price area we saw before.
So maybe we can make that
more clear by plotting, now,
the high value prices.
So let's go back up to where
we plotted all the red dots
and overlay it.
So this makes it
even more clear.
We've correctly shown how the
regression tree carves out
that rectangle in
the bottom of Boston
and says that is
a low value area.
So that's actually
very interesting.
It's shown us something
that regression trees can
do that we would never expect
linear regression to be
able to do.
So the question we're going
to answer in the next video
is given that regression trees
can do these fancy things
with latitude and
longitude, is it
actually going to help
us to be able to build
predictive models,
predicting house prices?
Well, we'll have to see.